a dark and scary the world might be
right now
there will be light Brooks I will find
the man who did this
so been sleeping by himself
I'm testing myself
offering can you teach me how to fight
yes I can I need you to get me a gun
doing this you won't ever be the same
that's what I'm counting on we go his
name the man that killed Bruce's parents
it's gonna kill him an I'm a monster do
it I wish you are a monster but you're
just a man I promise Bruce Wayne I'd
solve his parents murder
the Wayne case is closed you purpose
dead but who hired him why I need to
find out whatever your father was doing
he did it in secret for a reason
the man who contracted matches Malone to
kill your parents called himself the
philosopher he runs Arkham now Hugo
Strange I've been hired by a client to
attend an old Wayne Enterprises program
called Pinewood farms the program was
started by Thomas Wayne to cure
humanity's greatest ailments on the
genetic level old age disease even death
the program tried to play God and you
ended up creating monsters I was just a
researcher there's no knowledge of that
I believe you ran Pinewood farms I
believe you've restarted the program
only reason you're sitting in that chair
is because I allow him to let me ask you
why are you here
why she got under arrest the evidence we
have is far too tenuous I fear we're
going to the same path as before i me
won't get justice unless summer school
well you did to galavan
I chose to kill a man in cold blood
crossing that line you'll pay for it and
it will make you more like the evil
you're trying to fight here they know
what you've become what I turned you
into strong as an ox fastest is sneak
mad as a hatter his psyche could
reconcile death and rebirth until we
gave it a brand new context
command me that is a demon Kristen all
your lives in fire that case will give
you everything you need to destroy
try opening the chest my son
going to need something to wear
so in a nutshell Hugo Strange is make
the monsters out of dead people in his
spare time I know sounds far-fetched
far-fetched it sounds insane James
Gordon the time for you're pregnant
Cisco
I am angel of death change
tonight
I will show you the way to hell I know
the way
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got a
good look at Azrael on Gotham if you
don't know why they call this the movie
trailer they're just calling like a
cinematic trailer they're not actually
releasing a Gotham movie the cool thing
about the Azrael character he's been
around for a long time most of you
probably remember him as the guy who
took over for Batman after Bane broke
his back during the nightfall storyline
that all went down during that period in
the mid 90s when they were like okay
we're going to be super hardcore we're
gonna kill Superman so there's the big
Death of Superman arc and we're gonna
break the Batman those were the two big
events that actually got me started
reading comics or actually seeking them
out before then I really only bought
spider-man comics piecemeal when we were
on family vacations and I just like grab
a comic book and throw it in the bin
that my mom was buying groceries or
something like that but no matter how
old you are when you look at something
like this they're just like oh my god I
have to buy this I don't understand
what's going on but it looks so amazing
a lot of you might have seen him during
the Batman Arkham game just because that
game was so big they put almost every
single Batman character there's ever
been from the comics in it I think the
Azrael stuff was downloadable content
that they released after the initial
game came out so what happened is his
Azrael debuted as a character the year
before that nightfall storyline then
during 1993 during the nightfall
storyline he debuted as the new Batman
and if we were to characterize the
Batman is the Dark Angel of Gotham then
you understood where things were headed
when they call Azrael the Angel of Death
so justice got way more hardcore when
Batman recovered from his injuries he
had to take down as well just because he
got so hardcore Danny O'Neil long time
Batman writer creator of Rachel Ghul was
also one of the creators of Azrael he
actually said they had a lot of
character problems writing Azrael
because they wanted to take him from
being kind of a villain because he was
so hardcore to being a hero and it just
it didn't quite work out the way they
wanted to so I think it was part of the
reason why they brought the Batman back
so quickly it's like when they killed
Superman in the comics and you had the
reign of the Superman like a bunch of
people surface claiming to be the new
Superman
and a lot of people just aren't down
with it they're like this is lame I want
the version of Superman that I know I
want the real Superman to come back so
editorial is like okay we got to bring
Batman we got to bring Superman back as
fast as possible but the TV show Gotham
is actually combining a bunch of story
arcs from the comics they're combining
some early
as well storyline the storyline that he
actually started in was called Batman
sword of Azrael later he got his own
series then he came back for battle for
the cowl when Batman effectively died
during Final Crisis and a bunch of
Robins were fighting for the title of
Batman so they bring him back every once
in a while but in the comics he is not
created by Hugo Strange that's something
that the TV show has changed Hugo
Strange does create a lot of monsters so
what they're doing is they're combining
a big Hugo Strange arc from the comics
with an Azrael arc with Bruce's quest to
find out who killed his parents and
they've also changed that from the
comics too so in most versions of the
Batman origin story Joe Chill is the
person that kills his parents but what
the TV show has done is said that Hugo
Strange ordered the hit on his parents
because his father was trying to shut
down his research and on top of that
matches Malone is the person that
actually pulled the trigger matches
Malone in the comics is an alias that
Batman uses when he's trying to
infiltrate the mob so the TV show is
just mixing a lot of different aspects
of the Batman canon there's a lot of
stuff going on here but the cool thing
is is they're pretty upfront about what
they're doing like they'll say it out
loud like they say the name matches
Malone you know exactly what that is
when they say Azrael
you know exactly who that is there are a
few minor changes from the Azrael origin
story in the comics his name is
jean-paul Valley he's just like a normal
Gotham citizen that doesn't know that
he's part of this ancient lineage the
order of st. Dumas now on the TV show
theo galavan is a fake name by someone
from the Dumas family who was kicked out
of like the super special Club of
Gotham's founding fathers so they went
overseas founded the order of st. Dumas
and plotted their revenge so that was
like the first half of the season the
order of st. Dumas engineering the
downfall of the Wayne family in a coup
in Gotham the second half of the season
is kind of like an adaptation of Batman
in the monster men that storyline from
the comics Hugo Strange creates a bunch
of monsters that run rampant on Gotham
Batman has to clean up the mess it's
just that the TV show is just using a
bunch of very notable villains as those
monsters but if you've ever noticed
sometimes they'll drop verbal references
like they say he's mad as a hatter that
doesn't mean he's going to be the Mad
Hatter but the show will do Mad Hatter
at a certain point if you're confused
about the Batman villains the Gotham
gets to do they essentially have free
rein of the bat
and Canon they can do anybody from his
rogues gallery but I think there are
certain limits on that like they can't
do the exact same thing that the movies
are doing but for those of you asking
now that they've done a Supergirl
crossover with the CW DC shows I do
think that some day they could do a
Gotham crossover so they'd have to use a
multiverse explainer or the flash for
instance would have to go back in time
but because the tone of Gotham is so
much closer to the tone of arrow or even
Lucifer because Lucifer is a DC Comics
show that it's kind of off on its own
because it's based on a Neil Gaiman
character from his sandman comics which
is a vertigo title which wasn't part of
like the main DC Canon so I actually
like that Gotham and Lucifer both on Fox
there's a pretty good shot that they
could crossover if they really wanted to
but let me know in the comments what do
you think about Azeroth so far they gave
him the sword
he's got the suit so he's just going to
go out and start killing a whole bunch
of people now there's a bunch of other
stuff happening this weekend so I'm
going to try and do a couple extra
videos on Saturday before we get started
with Game of Thrones on Sunday there'll
be like a big game of Thrones catch-up
video too so be sure to subscribe to get
that stuff while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn all about zoom on the flash they
did a big reveal so it was kind of
confusing so I tried to explain the best
I could and you can click here to start
getting ready for Game of Thrones this
weekend thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you